o poder das ciências durante grande
parte da minha vida
também fiz investigação durante uma
quantidade x de investigação científica
durante uma quantidade considerável
tempo e sempre achei muito surpreendente
checamos estranhas figuras bata branca
quer que nós encontramos nos escravizam
não se parece em nada com xiitas que eu
conheço é e também sempre achei muito
surpreendente muito curioso
a quantidade de informações científicas
que nos encontramos com nós nos
deparamos no dia a dia por exemplo numa
ida ao supermercado é é preciso conceber
uma quantidade considerável
microbiologia para compreender que
aumenta a secção dos jogos é que a
yakult problemas bactérias normais que
estão presentes em todos os jogos
também tem algumas baterias especiais
têm direito no rótulo
isso nós avançarmos um que tem mais e
fomos até a secção das conservas de
peixe e até à secção dos congelados
depois precisamos também de receber uma
quantidade considerável de química para
perceber as diferenças entre todas as
gorduras presentes
quem é que sabe realmente realmente
explicar o que é o ômega 3 é perceber o
que é o ômega 3 nós precisamos receber
uma quantidade razoável de química
o ômega 3 um ácido gordo possa jogar o
ômega 3 é uma família de ácidos gordos
ou seja temos que perceber o que tem
química orgânica que receber um carro
com um grupo funcional que é um ace em
couro para onde também temos que
perceber que existem diferentes tipos de
ligações químicas entrar chutar bola
nós já temos perceberam que em teoria
das órbitas mônaco acho que estamos
conseguindo uma quantidade considerável
de química que é necessário tv para
conseguir o que quer dizer ômega 3
esta designação comercial mas falando
isso ainda quisermos saber é a ser que é
mais acerca das ambições dos benefícios
para seu dono de trecho a química já não
chega
temos que ver possivelmente alguma
bioquímica e fisiologia um ensina
possivelmente até podemos ganhar o
prêmio nobel eventualmente até tentar
fazer a nossa lista do supermercado
e também é uma coisa curiosa na secção
do sul
hoje em dia o consumo já não basta que
mata cedo o que tem um sabor agradável
no sul precisa de mais uma coisa que são
antioxidantes só perceber por que é que
serve os antioxidantes também uma tarefa
qualquer acontecimento oeste
primeiro temos que perceber as
implicações vivemos no mundo com
atmosfera carregada de oxigênio segundo
temos que perceber porque é que temos
que explodiam do próprio oxigênio que
respiramos terceiro
temos que perceber que mecanismos
naturais já que existem para fazer isso
e 4
temos que perceber que eles precisam de
uma ajuda é toda esta toda esta questão
do sul enquanto eu estiver me faz
lembrar uma frase de um bioquímico
chamado friends with conan o encontrei
no livro bioquímica quando estava a
bioquímica e é a primeira vez que nessa
popular e faz mais ou menos isto os
médicos gostam de aceitar vitamina c
milhões pessoas tomou não achem todo
mundo mas é preciso uma grande
substituição bioquímica para perceber
porque é que elas são necessárias
e como é que o organismo usa eo
percebido que falava porque ganhou o
prêmio nobel de química em 1911 química
não dando assim né
em 1953 por ter descoberto a enzima que
é um derivado da vitamina e é
absolutamente central para o pro moto
como as nossas células utilizam a
energia dos alimentos mas o clube
promete não sabia é que nós não
precisamos jamais de médicos para
receitarem vitaminas nós podemos aceitar
vitaminas a nós próprios no corredor do
supermercado unidão supermercado
transformou-se numa complexa aventura
farmacológica que requer conhecimento
avança vítimas para os quais nós devemos
estudar provavelmente durante um mês
como nos prepararmos para um exame mas
quer ser um segredo
os vendedores de insumos quanto em óxido
antes e os vendedores de de conservas
com 13
não quero que vocês isto é querem que
acreditem no bife dos ativos como quem
acredita em uma região no benfica
é todo um discurso ciências em ciência
em que se é chamada mas em que a própria
ciência está ausente do discurso porque
a ciência não é só um conjunto factos
volts
a alaya curiosidade a ciência é um corpo
de conhecimento e o modo de obter estes
cursos ciência não é exclusivo da
publicidade
o discurso se é ciência constitui a
maior parte do discurso massa sobre
ciência por exemplo muita gente exigir
mais conduzem a ciência é um conjunto de
curiosidades avulsas possam dar um
título sonantes como por exemplo os
homens com o campo com os homens que
cuidam dos filhos têm os tipos mais
pequenos como é que esta conclusão foi
obtida com as suas limitações do estudo
que metros foram usados não empresta
formada e tem muito dinheiro tem
testículos dançar o tango é ver se faz
melhor o coração e se vocês quiserem
marcar um dia para esta primeira e já
sabem
segundo a ciência o melhor viria a
empatar e deprimidos em alguns em
janeiro estiveram animados há qualquer
coisa de errado convosco e mesmo em
conversas de café s é usada como um
ponto final não é não
está provado cientificamente o tango é
melhor dança procuração
o regional o texto discurso ciências em
ciência é uma desgraça porque a ciência
não é isto assim não conjunto
curiosidades avulsas não conjunto
conclusões do relatório só que tinha
obtido de forma geométrica a ciência
começa como hipótese para testar é feita
uma experiência posso usadas metros
dessa experiência são obtidos resultados
que são sujeitos à deportação ter sempre
uma margem de subjetividade
tudo isto pode ter falhas por exemplo os
métodos utilizados podem ser mais de 4 e
condicionar os resultados podem mexer
para obter resultados enviesados que de
alguma forma distorcem a realidade por
não usar os métodos mais adequados
então podem ser retiradas conclusões
abusivas
é mas nada disto é um grande problema
porque assim não se baseia não cometer
erros
mexi na sua conversão esse é um processo
aberto e transparente e existe uma
comunidade científica e discutindo o
trabalho todo todos os investigadores e
outros investidores podem ter
experiências podem confirmar ou afastar
os resultados e ao fim de algum tempo
temos uma quantidade de conhecimento
razoável acerca de um terminal do
assunto quando já um número razoável do
grupo de investigação trabalharam sobre
ele e isto é ciência
e é isso que em grande medida está
ausente do discurso massas suficiência e
esta apresentação da ciência como uma
caixa negra de onde apenas saía
resultados e conclusões mais do que
resultados saem conclusões diretamente é
o treino oferta para a propagação de
idéias falsamente científicas concessões
encerradas ciência deficiência não tem
nada mas que se fazem passar por ciência
e um constante da pseudo ciência e o
mundo da ciência permite coisas
absolutamente extraordinárias não se
lembra uma história que aconteceu no
acontecimento que aconteceu em 2002
número na vila de são bartolomeu de
messines quando várias mulheres foram
contactadas por forma por outra mulher
que convidava é realizar uma mamografia
por satélite
portanto essas mulheres eram convidadas
a experimentar esta técnica inovadora
dirigiam se dirigiam a uma área
descampada onde estavam disponíveis para
a captação do satélite de no avanço da
cintura para cima e recebeu instruções
pelo fórum
às vezes os exames eram feitos em grupo
portanto portanto essa voz do fórum
orientava dinâmicas com vários pais mas
em simultâneo por vezes era necessário
mudar do local descampado exame para
melhorar a situação do satélite e à
noite
a falsa médica que fumava para dar os
resultados que tinha observado
e tô com binóculos e punitivo vários
orgasmos destas esta história caricata e
absurda que se que parece inacreditável
tenha conseguido convencer alguém tem
duas características principais da
pesquisa ciência é uma figura de
autoridade
neste caso é falsa médica e se não se
baseou em figuras de autoridade baseia
em provas e também contém também um uso
abusivo da linguagem científica tanto
uso de linguagem característica da
ciência mas neste caso sem qualquer
significado neste caso seria a tal
técnica inovadora que permitiria a
mamografia por satélite
o físico richa farina chamava comparar a
pseudociência da carga que é um conjunto
de rituais que o g1 que os que o que os
indígenas das ilhas do pacífico
começaram a fazer depois da segunda
guerra mundial é é algumas ilhas do
pacífico durante a 2ª guerra mundial os
norte americanos estavam baseadas ficou
com aviões traziam carga de uma forma
também trouxeram prosperidade e riqueza
e uma vida melhor próprios indígenas
destas ilhas então quando eu vou ganhar
os americanos foram embora e os
indígenas estavam todos voltassem então
eles começaram a fazer o que o o
ocorrido falha chamorro da carga seja
criaram pistas rudimentares da edição 10
11 homens numa das pistas como coisas
semelhantes a raquetes fizeram uma
campana como um pause e internas para o
controlador aéreo que dois corpos na
cabeça e fingir nos computadores
isso nos próximos dias voltassem atrás
por isso ficou conhecido como curva da
carga que o que mais amava mas faltava
alguma coisa
poucos dias no oitavo não é exatamente a
mesma coisa cup toda a linguagem e todas
as técnicas de ciência mas há uma coisa
que falta pouco vez na terra eo que
falta apoio da ciência para a seleção as
provas é toda a ciência é um problema
relativamente grave como é que nós
fazemos para acabar com a pobreza
ciência o perigo agora propor uma
infalível em 10 passos para acabar com
base na ciência mas provavelmente
escrita também pediu paciência porque é
sua ao antigo próprio à ciência e à
promoção da cultura científica e
promoção da cultura científica é uma
empreitada difícil e trabalhosa e
demorada e não há milagres
comecei a pensar neste assunto e na
altura lembrar de mim porque não
conseguem estar ciências lembrar de
quando era miúdo tinha cerca de 10 anos
recebi natal é uma prenda que era uma
caixa de experiências químicas em uma
certa região champion que eu queria
dissolver em água num tubo de ensaio tem
uma lamparina permite aquecer o essas
funções
lembro perfeitamente do tubo de ensaio
assegurado pela pizza sentir e munição
dentro do tubo de ensaio center que os
titãs extremamente excitante descobriu o
primeiro da ciência nessa altura havia
uma coisa que eu achava muito
interessante é que misturava do sport
não tinha um cheiro e um pomar cheiroso
ser o único
eu cheguei a vender harmonia ou um
colega meu da escola criminal ivo minar
o cão vai ter alguma forma um
comerciante de armas químicas
estou arrependido
rapidamente fez todas as experiências
que que estava no livro de instruções do
da caixa de empresas química
o meu colega não conseguiu eliminar o
cão
infelizmente e ainda tentou apresentar
uma reclamação mas a nossa ideia é eu
fiz todas as experiências que estavam na
caixa dependência química
resolvi inventar mais uma experiência já
é todo feito foi todas as experiências
de um livro de instruções nove etapas
mais uma experiência original preferido
é o sulfato de cobre azul e também
gostava de laranjas
então resolvi fazer uma experiência com
sulfato de cobre uma laranja
resolvi já tás o fato cobre o corpo de
mono jojoy maio e já temos o fato copa
no estado uma das metades da laranja
procure observar o infantil sulfato de
cobre na laranja
tenha certeza que ela produzisse um
afinal o fato do brasul então coronéis
dos resultados da laranja na outra não
já tem nada e fui anotando ao longo de
semanas o que acontecia
a princípio não houve festa nenhuma e
pois não estava com o dinheiro injetado
fato cobra laranja ficou verde pesquisa
e mal cheirosa ao passo que não está na
economia em que eu não tinha já tás o
fato cobra ficou verde esquerda e mal
cheirosa acaba por chegar à conclusão
que não tenha observado nenhum efeito o
fato cobra da laranja o que foi uma
grande desilusão em relação à cor azul
mas de uma forma fiquei contente por ter
uma conclusão e por isso se me
perguntarem qual é que seria se tivesse
apenas uma hipótese seria uma coisa para
promover a cultura científica e combater
a pseudociência o ensino experimental
das ciências fazer a experiência se as
pessoas souberem que o conhecimento
científico deriva da experiência de
resultados reprodutivos por outros
grupos de investigação coisas que nós
que os investigadores podem fazer e que
não dependem da autoridade ninguém em
particular nem do uso de uma linguagem
rebuscada muito mais dificilmente serão
enganados por vendedores de banha da
cobra muito bom poder